hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
colors are pretty important to us right
but when it comes to our devices for the
most part they really don't come in that
many colors maybe one two or three
colors at the most one every Apple
laptop in the world is silver the same
color every Apple keyboard in the world
is silver every trackpad every Magic
Mouse in the world they're all the same
color silver so the company color wear
is doing something about this colorizing
your devices but not just with a skin
that you can put on and then peel off
this is kind of taking it to the next
level
this is a color where custom MacBook Pro
I picked all the colors as you can see
here you probably guess that and cover
where has this design studio kind of
like moto maker but for a ton of
different gadgets they have headphones
mice keyboards laptops tablets phones
all kinds of stuff and if you've already
bought one of these devices you can pay
to have it colored and send it in and
I'll get painting or you can pay for a
brand new one to get that paint
treatment but yeah this is legitimately
painted in your color of choice not just
a skin so here's what I punched in on
the design studio on color website
pretty simple everything matte black but
with a cherry red hinge for an accent
and as it's arrived here it looks
exactly like that
everything matte black with that
beautiful cherry red hinge I think
that's a sick accent color you guys
already know I like red on black now
there are some parts here that are still
silver like the inside of the MagSafe
charger and the headphone jack and the
SD card reader stuff like that didn't
get painted which is smart because they
wouldn't work if they were covered in
paint and that's because of their super
detailed deconstruction and painting
process
so with this MacBook Pro for example
when you send it into color where they
actually completely take it apart they
look at the colors on your order and
then paint and coat each of the parts
individually before then putting
everything back together again
they actually reconstruct the MacBook in
their studio the only thing you see here
on my custom MacBook that you can't get
in the color where design studio is the
custom mkbhd logo on the back this is an
additional option they have usually for
like companies who want to bring a
branded laptop for presentations or
something like that
it's called the custom logo replacement
and actually disassemble behind the
display where Apple has the Apple logo
cut out and they will machine cut a
custom logo or text of your choice and
you can even work with our engineers to
get the backlight to work if you still
want it to glow when it turns on I did
and sure enough when you turn this
laptop on it glows I think this looks
absolutely ridiculously insanely good
and I think it's safe to say this is a
legit mkbhd Edition MacBook after the
surgery so when you get your laptop back
everything else in the packaging is the
same as a regular MacBook you get the
same accessories and everything plus an
added info sticker from
where and everything works the exact
same way it's still the MacBook Pro that
you paid for I'm basically in love with
this now so the one thing that remains
to be seen is how durable this kind of
stuff will be it's obviously painted on
so it's permanent not like a temporary
sticker and that's part of the reason I
didn't go with like a Ferrari red bright
painted laptop because you know that's
really cool after like a week but it's
permanent so a week later you have to go
to class to take notes and you're like
oh god I have a bright red laptop so I
did go with the more classy I think
understated more tuxedo black look and
design but again the durability is
what's gonna matter here because if you
scratch a silver Apple laptop there's
more silver underneath no big deal but
if you scratch this black painted Apple
laptop how many layers of black are
there before you get the silver again
and you can really see the damage and
how bad does that look obviously the
logo reconstruction is something very
unique and from me looking at the
materials that the logos made of it
looks pretty solid and it doesn't look
like it's gonna break anytime soon or
fall apart it's really precisely cut and
it matches exactly the logo that I
provided for them so that's really cool
but again it's gonna be interesting to
see how long this kind of paint lasts
and whether or not it scratches easily
also for those of you wondering about
color wear as a company I first found
them when looking for a black version of
the Apple keyboard as oddly specific as
that is and after I got it from color
where I it was you know it naturally
showed up in the background of videos
that showed up in a setup to a project
so people kept asking about it so I
reached out to them and we did this
custom MacBook Pro project nothing it
turned out pretty well they also do a
ton of other custom devices like I
mentioned ranging from the Magic
Trackpad or the Magic Mouse customized
to Beats headphones those are the least
expensive of the customs ranging to you
know a complete custom computer which
they have to disassemble and paint and
reassemble so that's a much more
expensive process and you'll see that
difference on their site and then the
top-of-the-line you know custom logo
replacement which is literally machine
cutting the logo you provide for them
into the metal and backlighting it which
is an engineering feat in itself but you
know you get to work one-on-one with
their engineers their artists their
designers and that ends up looking
pretty badass there you go guys thumbs
up for mkbhd Edition and MacBook
for I think it looks pretty sweet also
if you guys go to the cover worth site
and you customize something like looks
pretty sweet also take a screenshot of
it tweet it at me and I'll probably
retweet a couple of my favorites either
way thank you for watching and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace